so it's important to find out more about
Robert Maxwell because he himself was a
very very interesting character what do
we know about Robert Maxwell oh man well
I mean we could fill up the whole
podcast
thing about Robert Maxwell to be honest
but really his intelligence connections
are a matter of record
um he was uh very closely associated
with Israeli intelligence he was also
closely associated with figures and a
Soviet and Eastern European intelligence
to a significant degree
um in alleged relationship with British
intelligence I mean it seems like he
could have been a double or triple agent
um you know very involved with
intelligent stuff and that's why it's
complicated when we talk about
intelligence affiliations oh you know
people are like um you know Robert
Maxwell was just Mossad well you know
it's more complicated than that these
people are interested in money and power
for themselves a lot of times so if it
means you know you know helping these
guys out and helping these guys out
having your hands in as many pies as
possible to rake in more money for you
and stuff like that I mean a lot of
these guys seem to do that and Robert
Maxwell was definitely a guy that sort
of seemed to not just straddle and tell
it different intelligence agencies but
also intelligence and organized crime
which is another uh big theme of the
book so looking at Robert Maxwell by the
by the 19 around the end of the 1980s so
he went into business with Eastern block
Mobsters in a big way people like Simeon
mogulovich who whose name has come up
for example like when mainstream media
talks about Donald Trump in the Russian
mob and all of this stuff it all goes
back to Simeon mogulovich but they won't
acknowledge that uh he was a business
partner of Robert Maxwell and you have
Donald Trump partying on the lady galane
Robert Maxwell's yacht in in the same
period in the late 80s and all of this
stuff so is it really more of the
Maxwell Mafia or the Russian mafia right
there hasn't really been an interest in
connecting you know those dots right and
I think it's interesting too you look at
Donald Trump's reaction to Jeffrey
Epstein's arrest he wants to distance
himself I'm not a fan right and then
golane Maxwell gets arrested I wish her
well he says and people like um that
used to be pretty close to this Nexus
like Stephen hoffenberg say that Trump
was much closer to the Maxwell side than
the Epstein side from the from the
Father's Side Robert yeah and that it
continued you know that his affiliation
with Epstein and galane after Robert
Maxwell's death talking about Donald
Trump was because that he was closer to
galane than Epsy necessary well let me
ask you this how was Trump's
relationship with the Murdoch family I'm
not exactly familiar with that but but
because these guys were competitors
Maxwell and Murdoch were not we're
competitors yeah but Trump's Mentor was
Roy Cohn right and so Roy Cohn had a
friendly relationship with Murdoch got
it so these guys are going at it and
this character Robert Maxwell could have
been like a great Great Gatsby character
because he would tell the stories in
half the stories you don't know if it's
real or not but I thought yeah he was uh
he's been described as like narcissistic
a very very big on self-promotion very
you know he was determined to make
himself and his family sort of like the
next Kennedys he wanted to make a
dynasty of power uh that was what he was
interested Maxwell Robert Maxwell yeah
and um one of the top FBI special agents
in New York John Patrick O'Neill uh you
know went on record saying uh that
Robert Maxwell before he died set into
motion a global Coalition of criminals
that he basically uh made a major
successful effort to bring together
organized crime factions from around the
world into like a globe mobile basically
criminal conglomerate at the same time
that he has all these intelligence
affiliations and that's pretty
significant right keep going well I was
just going to say that O'Neill said you
know if you look into that guy's career
specifically you know he was sort of
head-oned to be head of the security at
the World Trade Center and he started
just days before 9 11 and he was sort of
pushed out of the FBI but before he was
he left the FBI and he made these
statements to author Gordon Thomas he
said I have people looking and Trust
still trying to unravel the Maxwell
Legacy in New York and this is a decade
after Robert Maxwell's death wow you
gotta realize that this guy was born you
know Czechoslovakian Ukraine right and
then uh his his parents and His Four
siblings get killed at a ashawitz I
don't know if it's a I don't know if it
was a camp but they they definitely did
die but they were also pilgrims and all
sorts of stuff
yeah they died he fought against the
Nazis for the British Military and so
then later Iran he goes into wanting to
compete in media the whole mirror and
then you know he owned 51 percent of uh
MTV it's kind of weird this guy owned 51
MTV Robert he owned 51 he was building a
mask
like a 51 of MTV and then this is Elaine
Maxwell's father father Robert Maxwell
so and then galane is the last child the
ninth the youngest yeah and his favorite
after the eldest son Uh Kevin injured in
a no the eldest son is injured I think
Michael Maxwell he dies uh after being
in a vegetative state for several years
he was the favorite Child and had this
you know awful car accident and then
galane who was uh Elaine was born around
the same time that happened with her
older brother and so uh the family
basically it neglected her for the first
like couple years of her life and she
developed like a childhood anorexia and
stuff and had a lot of problems with
feeling uh even acknowledged by her own
family which obviously is going to have
psychological stuff implement locations
for her obviously and then you know it
doubles back and then she becomes the
favorite child so you know you have that
neglect and then you go to being
favorite child you know there's a and
you sort of see Robert Maxwell start
there nine kids you sing I think it's
seven okay so all these kids was it with
the same woman and where were they all
born do you know okay yeah it was Betty
Maxwell is the the wife and very
complicated relationship there because
Robert Maxwell was not faithful
um and it doesn't seem like the kind of
guy no but she she was very faithful and
very devoted so you know yeah I feel
kind of sad for her to be honest
um but he was not faithful but he wanted
his children to be sort of like arms of
his Empire right yeah but two of them
are estranged I believe I forget their
names one went away to Argentina and the
other one uh he was not very nice to a
lot of his kids
um he was known to like verbally abuse
Evan and uh Kian and Evan uh sorry Kevin
and Ian and then
um the the daughter that's estranged he
insulted her appearance a lot and that
might have yeah is there any doubt in
your mind that he was an intelligence
asset Robert Maxwell I I just started
looking into this couple days ago
because it's all her fault I mean I
literally
I'm not the first though with Robert
Maxwell Seymour Hersh published a book
called The Samson option why Robert
Maxwell was still alive alleging a
relationship with Israeli intelligence
and in in Britain the libel laws are
very strong so Robert Maxwell sued over
that intelligence claim and he did not
win did not win and by the way here's
the same where Hirsch was right so we'll
just leave that there as far as I'm
concerned it's pretty it's extensively
documented the affiliation with Israeli
intelligence and and and and he names
his Yad the 50 million Auto yacht he
buys lady galane after his favorite
child after his favorite child but it's
a little weird the relationship between
Robertson
right for example galane commissions
pictures for the lady galane and some of
them are a bit racy
what does that mean
I don't know I mean father-daughter
relationship do you really want like a
picture of your daughter with the skirt
all the way up here being like
it's weird you know I'm not saying I
know anything that happened between them
but I think there was a lot of
psychological manipulation and you know
it seems like Robert Maxwell at least in
my opinion was kind of narcissistic a
lot of narcissistic parents see no
boundaries between them and their
children they see their children as
extensions of them he believed that
Elaine was the most sexually attractive
and the most like him
right so you know a lack of boundaries
can mean a lot of things in that in that
particular context right and you know as
I know in the book uh chapter 15
specifically which is about all this
stuff
um it seems like he you he was
interested in using her sexuality for
his benefit
um in in a PR sort of way
um like for example would publish
stories in his own papers of alleged
Affairs of his daughter with Elite
people you know Aristocrats and Britain
and stuff like that even though you know
the British Elites that he would name
were you know denied any sort of a
romantic relationship Robert Maxwell
obviously wanted that out there and this
is the same guy who with Colleen's you
know boyfriends when she was in high
school didn't want them near the house
didn't want her to date you know was
very controlling of her romantic life
but at the same time would publish you
know basically gossip and smutty gossip
in his in his newspapers about her I can
see most dads not wanting you know your
teenage daughter around but he wanted
her to marry a Kennedy that's what he
wanted oh really really oh yeah can we
see one picture Tyler and a young Elaine
Maxwell we all know what she looks like
now but young yeah and and after no one
knows how he died suicide you know a lot
of allegations but let's look at what
Elaine Maxwell says Elaine Maxwell
believes that he was murdered by Rogue
Assad agents and the Sicilian Mafia
that's what Elaine Maxwell thinks
happens to her father when does she say
that I think it's quoted in the New York
Post somewhere
um I cited in the book
she says uh he was murdered because they
you know the other children claim not
murder but she thinks she was she was
the person who according to British
journalists when he died she was the one
that came down out of all the siblings
came to the yacht right after his death
goes on the boat and shreds papers so
that means out of all the kids if that's
true out of all the kids she knew what
was incriminating and what was not where
it was and what to shred
yeah and by the way when he dies you
know who his yacht goes to his yacht
goes to Murdoch's third wife
it is interesting that's the part where
it's a very very
connection of wanting to compete in
media and how
uh the Murdoch Maxwell stuff was pretty
intense that competition uh Murdoch
drove Maxwell insane yeah looks at
things just he was he apparently was
willing to stretch his business Empire
you know as far as he could just to try
and stick Murdoch in the eye and that
that includes using 460 or 446 million
dollars of his employees retirement plan
yeah I know yeah did you hear this he
the pension fund for the for the mirror
he used his employees pension fund to
finance what he was doing with the media
company
446 million dollars and the employees
ended up only getting half of it at the
end after he died because his sons I
think Kevin and he didn't leave any he
didn't live any leave any any of his
money to galane he felt it was
appropriate to the boys or someone they
have trust in Liechtenstein no one knows
about all right and the FBI special
agents looking at this stuff in New York
you know Elaine apparently came and made
the show wearing like rags and like
sobbing being like dirty being like I
have no money but they didn't believe
her
and they were trying to find about all
these trusts and stuff that you know he
he was What Jeffrey Epstein did with
money Robert Maxwell was even better so
he so he so who knows really where the
money went we don't really know a lot of
the the Maze of Robert Maxwell's funds A
lot of it is honestly still a mystery so
if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
[Music]